depuis plus d'un mois les étudiants
chinois occupent le terrain les actions
ne sont pas improvisées à tel point
qu'aujourd'hui un comité de coordination
des manifestations a été nommé alors
côté vie quotidienne après plus d'un
mois d'action il a fallu apprendre à
vivre autrement
valérie fournier pékin se réveille et
s'achemine vers une nouvelle journée de
lutte contre le pouvoir dans quelques
heures ces ruraux regorgeront de monde
chaque jour les étudiants organisent de
nouveaux cortèges ballet incessant qui
irrigue la ville sous le regard parfois
impuissant de la police
bravant une fois de plus la loi martiale
il se dirige vers la majestueuse place
tiananmen rejoindre ceux qui ont veillé
près de 200 mille étudiants qui
soutiennent les grévistes de la faim au
fil des heures certains épuisés par une
semaine de jeunes abandonnent évacués
par les étudiants en médecine organisée
méthodique
je suis fier mon peuple est en train de
vivre et de faire ce qui ressemble à une
libération un peuple une foule souriante
devant les uniformes bientôt des
ouvriers des ingénieurs et même des
officiels des professeurs les retrouve
pour écouter les discours les consignes
ils iront ensuite manifesté dans les
grandes artères de pékin qui expose
encore les drapeaux en l'honneur de la
visite du numéro un soviétique malgré la
peur que les soldats interviennent place
tiananmen pour les 3000 grévistes de la
faim c'est la tante le bras de fer il
faut durer le front cerner d'une bande
de gaze prête à être abattu sur le
visage en cas d'agression ils
s'inscrivent aussi leur slogan demande
des signatures comme gage de soutien
cette nuit la population gardera nouveau
les rues pour empêcher les militaires
d'avancer vers la place de nouvelles
rumeurs d'entrée de l'armée dans pékin
circuleront d'angoise un soulagement
cette ville vivra une nouvelle fois sa
nuit la plus longue